hello everyone and welcome back to the
quarterfinals of the Delian Doris a be
rapid challenge it's the second match
between Lebanon and Cara Nakamura
Nakamura won the first one it was
actually 11 who took the lead but then
Nakamura equalized in the final final
game he was able to force Armageddon and
then he won in the Armageddon if you
haven't seen that game and now the
situation is the other way around
it's Nakamura who won in the previous in
round 1 and this is round work around
four against two and three would run and
now it's 11 with the white pieces who
needs a win at the force and Armageddon
and get back into the match and if he is
able to do that then they will play a
third match so let's see what happens
here 11 with the white pieces opens with
E 4 and Nakamura goes for a 5 we have
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and Bishop to
b5 so the reuleaux pieces on the board
and Nakamura goes for his Berlin defence
so Knight f6 and D 3 now not not eager
to go into some early Queen trading
lines of the Berlin
so Bishop to c5 and Bishop captures on
c6 so pretty much standard stuff B
captures and castles by white and here
as you're a pawn is under attack there
are always you know different ways you
could defend it like Queenie 7 even go
97 and f6 but Nakamura goes at Bishop to
d6 and it is it's not a new move but
it's it hasn't been played all that much
so Bishop to g5 now putting pressure on
the night here and h6
asked me do you want to capture or or go
back with Bishop to h4 and now Bishop to
g4 and we reach a game that it is a
future head against Vaughn how in the
2019 world blitz championship in Moscow
where h3 was played but here 11 goes for
Knight B to B 2 and it is already as a
move 9 that we have a completely new
game so let's see how Nakamura deals
with this he goes for the immediate the
g5 starts his expansion on the Kings
side Bishop g3 and not Knight to age 5
he goes after the light-square bishop or
in some cases depending on what place
the night might even come to f4 so here
at Knight to c4
eleven are saying that he now wants to
put pressure on Nakamura's dark square
bishop but also starts his expansion on
the Queen side so Knight captures ng3
and now f captures and g3 a little a bit
a bit of an unprincipled move since you
always want to capture towards the
center but it would be a bit dangerous
here since the night is still pinned
it's very uncomfortable for white and
you would you would have to worry about
a lot of things it would be easier to
push for Nakamoto for example on the
Kings side so instead after night
chapters and g3 with F captures and g3
now at least opening of the F file for
for 11th rook and the Queen to e7
Nakamura says I'm going to Castle
queenside so what are you gonna do about
it
xi starts with C 3 now he's preparing B
4 and a 4 and so on
so castles and B 4 of course we have
King to b8 a nice prophylactic move and
now not a 4 but rather a 3 problem with
a 4 is you don't really have a good way
of just pushing those points because if
you go all the way black and just
blockade and if let's say f6 and maybe
b5 then the problem is Bishop c5 you
lose control of the c5 square and the
King has to go to h1 and now after let's
say captures captures you push h5 and
it's very dangerous the King has nowhere
to go it wants hh4 happens you could
capture you could open up the th file
for the rook it will be very unpleasant
for white yeah so instead 11 does not
want to give away the control of c5 so
he just strengthens the position with a
3 but Nakamura just now continues
pushing on the King side as he it's a
it's castles on opposite sides so it's
of course you want to be the first one
to start attacking so h5 and now Knight
the e3 putting pressure on the bishop of
course if h4 than just Bishop hangs so
best back to c8 by Nakamura end now C
for preparing c5 here and here Nakamura
finds a most interesting move it seems
like c5 traps the bishop so nakamura
plays f5 and he invites c5 to trap the
bishop now how do you deal with this
the problem with C
five is that well it does trap the
bishop when Nakamura had in mind is
Bishop captures mc5 the point is that
the knight here is pinned and after you
recapture here now you capture on e4 of
course the pawn cannot capture due to
this and now the knight is under attack
and wherever you move the Knights it
doesn't really matter let's say 92 then
Queen captures on c5 you put pressure on
the night here you cannot move the knife
so you have to defend it let's say Queen
e2 or e1 not just for example rook
captures on d3 and the night will fall
black will regain the piece and have a
much better position
there's no way to defend the night if
you try and add another defender let's
say something like this then just b5
keeps their way it's not an issue for
Nakamura so instead after f5 we have
Knight captures on a5 by 11 attacking
Nakamura's queen we have Bishop captures
on f5 getting rid of the threat he
captures and now efore so nakamura
making some progress here however rook
to e1 putting pressure on the pawn now
and nakamura just advances it and with
this advance he has created a past one
on e3 and now what Levin should and
needs to do is something like would say
d4 at the keep an eye on the on the c5
square and the position the position
goes on next move you're gonna play c5
and so on however 11 played a queen to
c1 he immediately went for the pawn on
a3 but this this doesn't work all that
great because nakamora finds g4 he
dislodge is the night from f3 we have
Knight to the h4 NL Rookie H to e8 and
already a Nakamura's position is very
very comfortable the the past a pawn is
nicely protected and the white doesn't
really have all that much to show for it
so here a lemon did go for c5
but now you have Bishop to e5 going for
that rook and you didn't really you
didn't really manage to do anything here
it would be much better like we
discussed that the point was on d4 the
bishop would not have this e v square so
now the problem is if you play something
like rook to b1 just rook captures on d3
and then this is just too good of a
position for black and Levin is not
interested in playing this
so instead we have Queen captures on e3
which of course now you cannot capture
the root otherwise just Queen captures
on e7 and you would well we can just
show it if Bishop captures you can just
capture the Queen and after local
characters you can just capture on e7
and the problem is you don't have rook
captures and e3 because of background
issues this just results in mate
so after Queen captures on e3 of course
nakamora did not go for the rook he
played something else but this something
else also is completely winning for him
so here in fact the the Pinner becomes
the the peony so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find why this is
so well I give you a couple of seconds
win the game for Nakamura so for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting that well
the Queen and King are on a very
dangerous diagonal and for those who
just want to enjoy the show Queen f6 is
good however Queen to d7 is much faster
and this is what Nakamura place now the
rook is being threatened the bishop the
d4 of course the main thread just
winning the Queen and there's not much
to be done here for level 11 played
Queen to c1 he wants to offer the rook
to keep the game going
but Nakamura and not giving him any
chances he was for the absolute most
precise way Bishop to d4 with check so
King has the move doesn't matter where
you move the King King h1 was played but
now first rook captures and e1 with
Czech Queen captures and only now but
should characters on a one sole Queen
has to recapture otherwise you're just
down too much material and here Queen
captures and d3 and it was in this
position unmoved 28 that 11 Aragon
resigned the game and Nakamura
wins the second match as well which
means that 11 is out of the tournament
and Nakamura goes into the semi-finals
of the lewin Doris ABI rapid challenge
where he will face whoever whoever wins
that match the other match which I will
not disclose just yet as I will show
some other games
here he resigned as there is nothing
more to be done even though yes you are
only down the exchange but it's
completely
completely winning like this is just the
threat of checkmate so even if white
prevents that by moving the Queen like
the Queen e1 or Queens you want Queen c2
and there is no defense against the
rugged d1 just wins the Queen and you
are very quickly getting checkmated so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank a larger crab on
Andrew Gautier a Vijay Kumar Krishna
Sami a Konstantin Conrad and Gregory
Thomas for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Lin Doris Abby rapid
challenge checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day